que deviennent les patients sorti de
réanimation mais qui souffre toujours de
séquelles liées notamment au co vide
pour assurer un suivi à distance de ces
malades le chru de tours est une
start-up locales ont mis au point un
outil numérique sur ce site internet
c'est le malade qui renseigne son état
de santé par le biais de questionnaires
plus d'explications dans ce reportage
d'audrey champigny le 6 janvier dernier
barbara est testée positive à la cobi 19
très vite son état se dégrade en tube à
sion réanimation elle passera dix sept
jours dans le coma après une longue
période de soins de suite
elle rentre chez elle et opte pour
l'application kovy après une sorte de
questionnaires de santé par exemple
efforts physiques importants tels que
courir se lever un objet lourd ou faire
du sport je me sens quand même un peu
limité je ne peux pas faire encore ce
que je donc je vais cliquer par exemple
sur wii je vais valider ma réponse après
c'est rassurant de se dire on se sent
pas seul parce que on peut aller
manipuler le site on peut demander une
consultation si on veut et je me suis
rendu compte qu effectivement une fois
que j'ai rempli un médecin m'a rappelée
par rapport à ma voix j'ai ma voix qu'à
une faiblesse et qui m'a proposé
plusieurs plusieurs rendez vous est
peut-être voir un peu plus les examens
peu plus approfondie toutes ces
informations sont immédiatement
transmise par mail aux médecins
référents de réanimation sur son écran
le docteur salma peut alors évaluer la
situation de ces patients grâce à un
code couleur vert tout va bien rouge
c'est plus préoccupant pour le cas de
barbara l'affiché très détaillé
attention ce patient avait ce qu'on
appelle une neuropathie de réanimation
c'est à dire n'arrivait plus bien à
bouger était un peu paralysés au réveil
il va falloir surveiller comment ils se
déplacent ça gagne beaucoup en lourdeur
d'organisation sur l'organisation des
consultations
déjà parce qu'on est un service de
réanimation donc on n'a pas de lieu
dédié pour cette consultation donc c'est
toujours un petit peu compliqué de
trouver une salle du temps de
secrétariat pour planifier les choses et
s'est créé par une start up de mam
l'outil a été pensé pour des personnes
de plus de 60
longtemps de jeunes seniors qui
constituaient la majorité des patients
en réanimation au début de l'épidémie il
n'y a pas besoin de mode d'emploi il ya
des pictogrammes en fait qui montre en
fait la signification du bouton fait
tout simplement là par exemple humeur du
jour c'est une petite météo avec un
orage enfin un nuage depuis un soleil et
on comprend que si je mets le fallait ça
veut dire je me sens bien je vais bien
pour les passions qui n'auraient pas la
fibre numérique
il existe également l'équivalent au
format papier sinon enfants et petits
enfants sont parfois mises à
contribution